thank you
so much for doing this i'm a huge fan of
your work inside and outside the office
so
oh thanks great to speak with you i
wanted to ask i mean
a huge part of the office throughout its
entire run is callbacks uh with the
teapot being one of the favorites of the
fans
i was curious if you had a favorite
callback throughout the run of the show
uh goodness i just saw the finale again
on the night that it left
netflix that's uh and i feel like there
was a lot of callbacks
in in that episode um
trying to remember some of the good
ones i think maybe uh kevin
saying well well and getting the number
wrong was
a fall back to his his bad um
you know math abilities yeah yeah for
sure
that's a good one uh well speaking of
season nine it
you know it's the most dramatic of the
show and i i really like that shift for
it
and i know there was talk of of maybe
splitting jim and pam up
and so i was curious if you could kind
of talk about what your guys's plan was
for those characters kind of in the
interim if the plan was indeed to split
them up and then get
the them back never to split them up uh
the plan was just
to introduce a little worry um
into the audience so that they'd stand
up and pay attention and you know that
there would be a little
feeling of um like the act two break in
a movie you know
so um but uh no there was never any
there was never going to be a split up
for them uh there was always a happy
ending plan yeah
well you executed a little too well
because that season is still hard to
watch no matter how many times
i've seen it it was not it was not the
happy thing for people but i feel like
you know
the um the ending of the series was uh
was good and maybe it wouldn't have been
so satisfying if there hadn't been a
little bit of
uh anxiety beforehand i agree with that
it feels truthful
and to relationships as well um uh well
another big thing that happens in season
nine is finally dwight is made manager
uh and i was curious if for you if that
felt like finally fulfilling something
because i know there was talk of
you guys were close to maybe making
dwight the manager when when steve left
did it feel uh like you were finally
kind of fulfilling a long-held goal
there
yeah definitely um you know and i think
that uh
so much about the ending is just
finding out you know did people grow
that they kind of learn something and
then get rewarded for it
and you know dwight uh quite matured a
lot and
you know gained a lot of social skills
and
you know was i think the better person
at the end so he should get his
his his dreams was there ever any regret
on your part of not making dwight the
manager earlier or
did it feel like kind of the right time
to do it just as the show was ending
um well you know the transition period i
wasn't running the show that was paul
lieberstein
um for season seven and eight i was uh
you know
an ep but i wasn't running it so i don't
know i mean we certainly discussed a lot
of different
uh options but you know
the character of dwight was not built to
be the lead you know he's a he's an
antagonistic character and it's so
i i don't know if it would have worked
to take that element out of the show and
turn him into
the lead of the show when he wasn't for
sure i mean i think
you know andy wasn't 100 built for it
either because he was the dwight of
stamford so
yeah you know yeah uh i have to wrap
with you i'm sure you're gonna get this
question from everyone but i have to ask
now that it's on peacock
is a continuation of the office in
active development at this point
uh no but i mean it's not impossible
it's not it's not impossible for sure
but um i would want to be involved and
i'm
i've got two other shows that i'm
working on right now
awesome well thank you so much and
speaking of which i cannot wait for the
next season of upload i
i adore that show oh thank you so much
i'm in vancouver now
uh getting ready to to shoot it so
awesome
well i can't wait uh thanks again for
doing this really appreciate it
my pleasure adam nice to meet you